>>> WELCOME TO THE SHOW,
EVERYBODY.
MY NAME
AND BE.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE MAN ON THE
SHOW WE LIKE TO CALL PRODUCER
RYAN.
HE IS THE ONE THAT GELS ARE TO
YOU GUYS.
LAST WEEK, WE BUILT THE PARLAY
AND --
>> HE JOINS KLAY THOMPSON ON
OUR BRANDS LIST.
FOR THOSE THAT DO NOT KNOW WHAT
THAT IS, THAT MEANS WE ARE
NEVER, EVER, EVER TOUCHING YOU
AGAIN.
>> HE IS ON THE BANNED LIST.
WE WERE FEELING GOOD.
WE GOT FIVE OUT OF SIX.
AUSTIN REED DID NOT SHOW UP BUT
WE ARE HERE TODAY, RUNNING IT
BACK.
WE ARE IN THE CHAT, INTO A
PARLAY.
RYAN, WHAT DOES THE CHAT LIKE
TONIGHT?
>> THOMPSON CAME HERE AND SAID,
I WANT BIG ODDS BUT WHAT ABOUT
PLACE?
>> ISN'T THAT THE GOAL?
>> DON'T WE ALL, BROTHER?
DON'T WE ALL.
>> ALSO, HE CAME IN AND SAID,
HE THINKS THAT THE JOKER -- I
WILL NOT TRY TO SAY THAT.
WE ARE STARTING OFF HOT.
THEY SAY HE WILL NOT HAVE MORE
THAN EIGHT ASSISTS TONIGHT.
>> OKAY.
OKAY.
>> LET'S GO CHECK IT OUT.
>> WE ARE STARTING OUT IN THE
LATE GAME.
>> GREG -- YOU USUALLY ARE THE
NUMBERS GUY.
YOU WANT TO PULL UP WHAT THE
ASSIST NUMBERS LOOK LIKE?
IT IS INTERESTING THAT WE WILL
START WITH -- JOKER HAS BEEN
PLAYING AT AN MVP LEVEL YET
AGAIN.
NO ONE SHOULD BE SURPRISED.
I THINK EIGHT ASSISTS ARE
INTERESTING.
>> MB?
HOLD ON.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ASSISTS.
HERE WE GO.
FIRST OFF, RYAN, I GOT CAUGHT
UP SAYING THESE TWO NAMES.
I KNOW HOW TO SAY HIS NAME.
HE HAS 10, EIGHT, EIGHT, 14,
NINE, EIGHT, NINE, 12 -- SHOULD
I KEEP GOING?
>> HERE IS -- THIS IS JUST WHAT
I DO.
I DID NOT HEAR A NUMBER BELOW
EIGHT.
DO WE JUST DO EIGHT PLUS?
>> YES.
>> OKAY, COOL.
>> WAS IT 8 1/2?
>> IT WAS.
>> DO NOT WANT TO DO SIX?
>> OH.
OH.
>> I AM JUST TRYING TO WIN.
>> HEY.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT ELSE WE HAVE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> DO WE WANT TO STICK TO THIS
GAME?
I AM ALSO SEEING THE WIZARDS
PLUS SEVEN.
THE STREET RATE, IT IS NO SWEAT
FOR US.
IF YOU BET 25 PLUS DOLLARS AND
YOU LOSE, WE GET THE MONEY
BACK.
WE WILL STICK TO THE TEAMS.
LET'S SEE.
>> SOMEBODY SAID I AM NOT EVEN
GOING TO LOOK AT THE GRIZZLIES'
CENTER DEFENSE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT JOKIC.
THE MATCHUP DOES NOT REALLY
MATTER IN THIS SITUATION.
>> I WILL NOT WORRY ABOUT THE
JOKER.
>> WE CAN JUMP TO THE OTHER
GAME BECAUSE I AM SEEING A LOT
OF JULIUS RANDLE.
>> I SEE HIM IN THE COMMENTS
TOO, BRO.
>> AND THEN I SEE E DADDY WITH
THEM OVER 21.5.
LET'S GO OVER TO THAT OTHER
GAME.
>> SO THE TWO GAMES -- I DO NOT
WANT TO CHARGE THEM.
>> I DO NOT WANT TO TOUCH HIM.
>> HE HAD A PRETTY GOOD
OFFENSIVE GAME.
>> DID HE?
>> YEAH, HE DID.
I THINK SOMEBODY I KNOW HAD
HIM, LIKE, UNDER POINT AND HE
WENT OVER, WHICH IS RARE FOR
HIM.
EITHER WAY, WITHOUT -- IT IS
KIND OF SPOOKY THESE DAYS.
>> YEAH, FACT.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT, RYAN?
HE IS OVER 24 1/2?
>> AT, BUT THE NUMBER I GOT WAS
21 1/2.
I DO NOT LIKE THAT.
IT IS OFF.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO THOUGH.
>> MAYBE WE ARE GOING 20?
>> ALL RIGHT, LET'S SEE.
-400.
WHAT DOES THIS DO FOR US?
>> ALL RIGHT, WE SAID WE WILL
GET -- HE IS TRENDING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THEY ARE ALSO DROPPING IN
JORDAN POOLE OVER FOUR ASSISTS.
>> EASY MONEY.
HE IS A STARTER.
>> THE NUMBERS ARE UP 5 1/2.
LET'S PURCHASE IT DOWN TO FOUR.
>> I LOVE THIS.
>> WE ARE AT -- WE ARE IN PLUS
MONEY TERRITORY.
THESE ARE THINGS WE ARE
CONFIDENT IN.
>> THE CHANNEL IS DOING THEIR
JOB TONIGHT.
>> YEAH.
>> THEY SAY -- THE CHAT IS
DOING THEIR JOB.
WE ARE DOING OUR JOB.
I LOVE THE WAY WE ARE
MONITORING THESE AND GOING TO
THESE 20+, 4+, AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT IT THAT WAY.
THE CHAT IS TALKING ABOUT
RAYMONDS REBOUND TOTAL.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT HIS
REBOUND TOTAL.
>> OKAY.
JUST REAL QUICK, LET'S REVIEW
WHAT WE HAVE SO FAR.
WE HAVE JULIUS RANDLE, 20 PLUS
POINTS.
JORDAN POOLE, FOUR PLUS
ASSISTS, AND THEN JOKIC  EIGHT
PLUS ASSISTS.
>> THAT IS PRETTY GOOD.
SO, MY ARGUMENT FOR BYE GAIT
REBOUNDS AS I SAW  THEM AGAINST
THE BULLS LAST WEEK AND THEY
MISSED A LOT OF SHOTS.
THEY TAKE A LOT OF EARLY
POSSESSION SHOTS, SO THE
OPPORTUNITY COULD BE THERE TO
HAVE A BUNCH OF REBOUNDS.
THE PROBLEM I HAVE ON THE OTHER
SIDE IS WILL DRAYMOND PLAY  --
HE WILL BE RUNNING AROUND THE
THREE-POINT LINE KIND OF A LOT.
>> YEAH.
THAT IS A GOOD POINT.
THEY ALSO GO SMALL BALL.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
>> IF HE PLAYS THE FIVE, THEN
YOU COULD PUT -- WHAT I SAW IS
I HAD CURRY SWITCHING WITH
JULIUS RANDLE.
MAYBE THEY WILL DO THE SAME
THING.
SIX REBOUNDS DOES NOT SEEM LIKE
A LOT.
>> WE CAN PUT A PIN ON IT.
I AM NOT SOLD ON THAT.
I AM NOT SOLD.
WE CAN PUT A PIN ON IT.
A PIN IN IT.
I SAW SOMETHING THAT WAS VERY
INTERESTING.
SOMEONE SAID THAT HE WAS OVER
20.5.
>> WE ARE ALSO GETTING SOME
JORDAN POOLE.
IF WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT,
JORDAN POOLE IS -- I THINK --
YOUR IS THE DEAL.
I THINK WE NEED ONE REALLY
COMPETENT PLUS ONE PLAYER RIGHT
NOW.
SO, I AM DOWN TO GO OVER TO THE
OTHER GAME AND WE WILL GO TO
THE GRIZZLIES AND THE NUGGETS.
>> VEGAS IS EXPECTING THIS GAME
TO BE NOT ONLY HOT, BUT ALSO
VERY CLOSE.
SO, POINTS?
>> THE GRIZZLIES?
THE GRIZZLIES?
>> YOU ARE THINKING OF ADDING
THE GRIZZLIES TO THE PARLAY?
>> IS A PLUS MONEY?
>> I DID NOT THINK THEY WERE.
THEY ARE MINUS 104.
>> I LIKE IT.
LET'S ASK THE AUDIENCE THOUGH.
IT TOOK OUR PARLAY TWO PLUS
333.
WE ARE TRENDING.
>> WE DO NOT HAVE TO GO TOO
CRAZY.
THE NEXT TWO PLAYS ARE BIG.
>> THIS WILL BE WHAT DECIDES
IT, FOR SURE.
>> THE NEXT TWO ARE DEAD.
IF YOU LIKE THE GRIZZLIES
MONEYLINE PLAY, WE NEED THUMBS
UP IN THE COMMENTS OR THUMBS
DOWN IF YOU DO NOT LIKE IT.
BUT RYAN -- I AM LOOKING AT THE
COMMENTS ABOUT JA MORANT.
HE IS AT 28.5.
I DO NOT KNOW.
>> THIS IS TOUGH.
RIGHT NOW, WE ARE JUST GETTING
STRAIGHT, LIKE, -110 OR -118
PLAYS.
>> IF YOU LIKE THE WAY TO GO
ABOUT THIS IS WE ARE GETTING
MIXED SIGNALS ON THE THUMBS
UP/THUMBS DOWN WITH THE
GRIZZLIES.
I FEEL LIKE THE WAY I GO ABOUT
THIS IS THREE-POINTERS.
I THINK THAT IS WHERE I FEEL
THE MOST COMPETENT IN TERMS OF
PLUS MONEY.
>> WE DID ONCE TAKE JARON
BRONSON OVER -- THAT WAS THE
PART WE WON.
HE KNOCKED DOWN A BUNCH OF
SHOTS AND WE DO NOT HAVE TO
JUMP BACK AND FORTH, BUT I
AGREE.
THE THREE-POINT PROPS ARE
DEFINITELY WHERE TO GO.
>> I HAVE A QUESTION.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
DO YOU ALL AGREE THIS IS GOING
TO BE A HARD SCORING GAME?
AM I RIGHT OR WRONG?
>> THEY ARE GIVING US SOME
DOWNS ABOUT THE GRIZZLIES BUT
THEY SAID, OVERALL, THERE MIGHT
BE SOMETHING TO LOOK AT, BUT --
IT IT IS GOING TO BE A HIGH-
SCORING GAME, DON'T THEY KNOW
THAT JA MORANT IS GOING TO
SCORE?
>> DEFINITELY.
>> HAVE YOU EVER TAKEN AN
ALTERNATE POINTS TABLE?
>> I LIKE WHERE YOU ARE GOING
WITH THIS.
YOU ARE SAYING 30 PLUS?
>> 30 PLUS?
>> JUICY.
>> I WISH I WOULD HAVE DONE A
LITTLE MORE.
>> THAT WAS A SIGH OF
DISAPPOINTMENT.
>> I WISH WE WOULD HAVE DONE A
LITTLE MORE, BUT IT IS A PLUS
MONEY PLAY.
I AM CONFIDENT.
I WILL PLAY FROM ONE OF OUR
COMMUNITY CAPTAINS.
HE IS PLUS 100, JULIUS RANDL.
I WATCHED HIM SHOOT 53'S . HE
ALSO WAS IN A PARLAY.
HE DEFINITELY MADE TWO RIGHT
AWAY.
SO, MAYBE INSTEAD OF TAKING
RANDALLS POINTS, MAYBE WE DO
THE THREES BECAUSE APPARENTLY
IT IS  --
>> DON'T YOU THINK THEY KIND OF
GO HAND IN HAND IN A WAY?
HE IS NOT -- IT BEGETS MORE
THAN TWO THREES, HE WILL NOT
GET 20 POINTS.
BUT I FEEL LIKE I DOUBLING UP
ON JULIUS, I FEEL LIKE I AM
COMFORTABLE DOUBLING UP IN THAT
WAY.
>> YEAH.
MY POINT WAS INSTEAD OF GETTING
THOSE POINTS, BLOCKING THE
THREES, THAT IS BETTER VALUE.
>> OKAY.
>> IF WE ARE TRYING TO MOVE THE
VALUE.
>> YEAH.
IT MIGHT BE WORTHWHILE.
>> YOU GUYS, THOMPSON WHO IS A
LOYAL FAN OF THE SHOW, I MEAN
IF YOU TAKE HIM AT 30 PLUS, YOU
MIGHT AS WELL TAKE JOKIC AT
NINE ALTERNATE REBOUNDS.
I'M NOT SAYING YOU HAVE TO DO
IT, BUT THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S
PARLAY.  I
WANTED TO HAVE THAT IMPACT.
>> I DO NOT HATE THAT.
HE HAD THAT 27 REBOUNDS THE
OTHER DAY.
>> AND VEGAS IS EXPECTING A LOT
OF POINTS, SO THERE WILL BE A
LOT OF SHOTS TAKEN.
NINE REBOUNDS FROM JOKIC DOES
NOT SEEM THAT CRAZY.
>> HE IS ALSO QUESTIONABLE IN
THIS GAME.
EVEN IF HE DOES PLAY, I AM NOT
SURE  -- I QUESTION THE
ASSISTS.
>> WHILE YOU GO THROUGH THE
CHAT, I WILL CHECK ON MY
SOURCES ON HIS INJURY AND SEE
WHAT IS UP.
>> HEY, RYAN?
>> YES, SIR.
>> I SEE JORDAN POOLE WITH TWO
THREES.
I LIKE THAT.
>> I FEEL BETTER ABOUT THIS
OTHER GAME.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
ABOUT THIS WARRIORS GAME WITH
THE NEW YORK KNICKS.
OH, MAN.
>> 3 1/2?
>> WE ARE EXPECTING A LOT OF
JORDAN POOLE TONIGHT.
>> GO TO THE 2+ AND SEE WHAT
THAT DOES FOR US.
NEVERMIND.
>> I MEAN, WE COULD -- AS A
THROW IN LEG,  BUT I DO NOT
KNOW.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THREE THREES?
>> WE CANNOT DO THREE FLAT.
WAIT, NO, I AM A LIAR.
THAT IS ON ME.
>> NOW IT IS MOVING.
>> YES, AND -- WHAT WE CAN DO
IS WHAT YOU SAID BEFORE, WHICH
IS WE CAN TAKE OUT JULIUS
RANDLE --
>> AND WE CAN SEE WHAT HIS
THREES ARE.
>> FOR TWO PLUS?
>> YEAH.
>> IT IS ABOUT THE SAME.
>> THIS IS TOUGH.
THIS IS DIFFICULT.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT HAS A
CERISE THAT WOULD LIKE?
JALEN BRUNSON, JULIUS RANSOM --
>> HE SEEMS TO HAVE THE MOST
VALUE WHAT THEY WANT SOMEONE IN
THIS GAME FOR THREES.
IT IS 2 1/2 TWO PLUS MONEY FOR
RJ BARRETT.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE CLOSE TO
EVEN.
>> -210.
THAT IS AS TO WHERE WE FEEL
COMFORTABLE ABOUT IN TERMS OF
-- THAT IS FIVE PLAYS PLUS 5:35
.
>> HOW MANY DOES HE HAVE TO
MAKE?
TWO?
>> YEAH, JUST TWO.
THE LEGS WE HAVE ARE JOKIC WITH
EIGHT PLUS POINTS,  JORDAN
POOLE WITH FOUR PLUS ASSISTS,
JULIUS RANDLE WITH THREE THREES
--
>> I'M LOOKING AT RJ BARRETT
AND HIS LAST FIVE.
2 DEGREES AND FOUR THREES.
BUT THE BIG ONE IS VERY MUCH
RECENTLY, 0-5. SO, IS HE HOT OR
COLD?
>> OH, BOY.
>> THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
>> YOU JUST NEVER KNOW.
>> I DID THINK THIS GAME
PROBABLY SETS UP NICELY FOR
HIM.
I THINK THE WAY HE PLAYED
AGAINST THE BULLS PROBABLY
GIVES ME -- HE WENT 0-5 BUT HE
WAS 10-19 FROM THE FIELD.
>> WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
GUY BEFORE THE SHOW.
QUINTON GRIMES HAS BETTER ODDS.
>> THE CHAT IS REALLY
INTERESTED IN HIM.
THAT IS WHY WE LOVE YOU.
>> WE HAVE TO CONNECT WITH THE
PEOPLE, GUYS.
WE HAVE TO CONNECT WITH THE
PEOPLE.
HE DOES NOT TRUST RJ.
CHAD OUT TO HIM.
HE SAYS HE IS COLD, SO LET'S
SWAP OUT RJ FOR QUENTIN GRIMES.
>> YEAH.
I AM SEEING RON STAN TWO PLUS
THREES AND I'M TRYING TO SEE IF
THERE IS A LEAD THAT WE ARE
JUST NOT COOL WITH.
>> I AM DEFINITELY IN ON JOKIC
WITH ASSISTS.
AS LONG AS HE FINISHES THE GAME
-- EVERYTHING I READ SAID HE
WAS PROBABLE.
MY BAD.
>> YOU WANT MY HONEST OPINION?
THAT WHOLE THREE THREES --
>> IT SCARES YOU?
>> I AM SKEPTICAL.
>> OKAY.
>> EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE,
THAT IS THE ONE I AM LIKE, OH --
>> YEAH, AND THAT -- WHAT ARE
THE ODDS ON THAT?
THAT IS MINUS 390.
WE CAN FIND SOMETHING THAT WE
FEEL A LITTLE BETTER WITH.
SO --
>> LET'S ASK THE AUDIENCE.
LET'S LOOK AT THE CHAT.
EVERYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT
BRUNSON.
>> JALEN BRUNSON HAS TWO PLUS
THREES.
>> YOU KNOW --
>> ICE OUR PARTY MIGHT BE SICK
WITH COVID.
>> NEVERMIND.
NEVERMIND.
>> LET'S MAKE SURE.
>> HE IS NOT IN HERE TO TAKE
ANYWAY.
>> WHAT ABOUT -- I DID NOT SEE
THIS IN THE CHAT.
I AM USUALLY A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE BUT WHAT ABOUT JONATHAN
KUMINGA?
THE ROOK HAS BEEN BAWLING.
>> WHY AM NOT ABLE -- I GUESS
THERE IS NO OTHER OPTION HERE.
>> THEY ARE ON TO US.
>> THIS IS INTERESTING.
I AM SEEING A LOT OF
INTERESTING COMMENTS AND THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT JORDAN POOLE.
>> IT SEEMS POSITIVE.
>> AS A MICHIGAN FAN AND A FAN
OF HIS OVERALL, THAT KID LOVES
THE BIG SPOTLIGHT.
I THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE A BIG
NIGHT.
I THINK HAVING TWO ODDS OF HIS
IS PROBABLY TOO MUCH, SO WE
HAVE TO PICK WHICH ONE WE LIKE
THE BEST.
I THINK HE IS DEFINITELY GOING
TO HAVE A GOOD GAME.
>> I MORE SKEPTICAL ABOUT HIM
PASSING THE BALL THAN I AM HIM
CHUCKING UP THREES.
THAT IS JUST MY TAKE ON THAT.
>> B THOMPSON SAYS -- THEY SAY,
IN DOMINGO WE TRUST.
>> ARE YOU SEEING THIS LOVE?
>> I AM.
>> YOU SAW THAT?
>> I LOVE ME SOME BONES.
>> HE IS SUCH A STUD.
>> NOT THE TV SHOW.
THE GUY FROM THE NUGGETS BONES.
YEAH, SORRY IF WE HAVE SOME
BONES FANS IN HERE.
>> WE SHOULD NOT TALK -- IT IS
PRETTY CLOSE TO OUR COMPANY'S
HEART.
ANYWAY --
>> COME ON.
I WANT TO BET ON BONES.
>> OH, MAN, THAT IS TOUGH.
>> WE HAVE TO GET TWO PLAYS
SUPER SHARP.
DANG IT.
MY BOY KUMINGA IS NOT PLAYING.
>> MAN, I WANTED BONES.
>> THEY ARE SAYING THAT THREE
THREES IS THE PLAY, NOT
ASSISTS.
>> THAT IS WHAT I WAS SAYING
BEFORE.
>> THEY SAY THAT JORDAN POOLE
IS GOING OFF OF MADISON SQUARE.
I LIKE IT, MAN.
>> WHAT WE CAN DO IS WE CAN
TAKE OUT HIS ASSISTS AND WE CAN
JUST PAIR UP  25 PLUS.
WE CAN GO OVER TO HIS POINT AND
PAIR IT UP WITH THE THREES.
IF WE ARE SAYING THIS IS GOING
TO BE A JORDAN POOLE KIND OF
NIGHT, THEN WE CAN GO DOWN HERE
AND DO THIS AND SEE WHAT THAT
DOES.
>> YEAH, JUST DO THAT.
>> WE CAN GO TO 20 POINTS.
LET'S SEE WHAT THAT DOES FOR
US.
NOT ENOUGH.
NOT ENOUGH FOR ME.
THAT IS 476.
>> IT IS NOT ENOUGH IF WE FEEL
LIKE WE ARE LOCKING THIS IN.
WE CAN PUT 20 IN AND MAKE ONE
MORE MOVE, BUT WE DO LIKE -- I
DO LIKE WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
I AM NOT SURE WE NEED TO PAIR
THEM UP BECAUSE IT WOULD SUCK
FOR POOLE TO MAKE  THREE OF
SEVEN THREES AND END UP WITH 22
POINTS.
>> THE CHAT IS ALL OVER THE
THREES.
>> OKAY.
HEY, THE CHAT IS THE CHAT.
THIS IS THEIR PARLAY.
>> WHAT I DO, GREG, WHEN I FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT THIS IS I TAKE A
CLIP FROM THE SHOW, SO WHEN IT
LOSES I POST IT, SO EVERYONE
KNOWS I DID NOT SUPPORT THIS.
>> I AM NOT A RECEIPTS GUY.
I AM JUST AN INSURANCE GUY.
>> WHAT ABOUT -- WE ARE GOING
FOR PLUS MONEY.
SOMEONE IN THE COMIC JUST SAID,
JORDAN POOLE'S PLAYER COMBO.
CAN WE HAVE THAT?
>> I DO NOT KNOW IF YOU'RE ABLE
TO SEE THAT.
NO, YOU CANNOT SAME GAME
PARLAY, UNFORTUNATELY.
SO, I AM COOL WITH -- MAN, THIS
IS TOUGH.
>> WE ARE GETTING A LOT OF LOVE
TO BRUNSON.
>> I DO NOT KNOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I AM COOL WITH THIS BUT I
ALSO LIKE PLUS 495.
IT IS NOT NECESSARILY, FOR FIVE
LEGS, IT IS NOT WHAT YOU LOVE
TO SEE.
>> LET'S GET A BOOKIE.
LET'S JUST GET A BOOKIE AND --
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
YEAH.
I LIKE IT.
LET'S GO THROUGH IT.
JORDAN POOLE, PLEASE PLUS
THREES.
QUENTIN GRIMES,  TWO PLUS
GOLDEN POLL, 20 PLUS POINTS.
JOKIC, EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS AND
JA MORANT WITH 20 PLUS POINTS.
>> I AM NERVOUS.
>> WHAT MAKES YOU NERVOUS?
>> I AM JUST -- I DO NOT KNOW.
I DO NOT KNOW.
I COULD NOT TELL YOU.
>> IF ANYTHING, I AM NERVOUS
ABOUT 30 POINTS BUT I KNOW JA
MORANT CAN GET IT.
>> JA, WHO -- WHO WAS GOING TO
GUARD HIM?
JAMAL HARRY?
JOKIC?
>> NO.
>> I AM NOT WORRIED ABOUT THAT
AT ALL.
THE THREES CONCERN ME, BUT I AM
ROCKING WITH IT.
I DO THINK HE IS GOING TO BE
DISHING THAT BALL AROUND.
JORDAN POOLE --
>> JA MORANT ONLY PLAYED 16.
HE HAS HAD  --
>> THEY CANNOT GUARD HIM.
THAT IS FOR SURE.
>> WE DO NOT HAVE MUCH TIME
LEFT.
THE ONLY THING THAT SCARES ME
IS THE CHEAPPRESENTS.COM
ASSISTS.
YEAH, I DO NOT KNOW.
>> WE JUST WENT THROUGH HIS
NUMBERS.
YOU WANT ME TO SAY THEM AGAIN?
>> I KNOW, BUT I AM ALWAYS
WEARY OF TAKING A GUY OFF OF A
HISTORIC GAME, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?
HE HAD 27 REBOUNDS AND 10
ASSISTS?
IF YOU WERE TO WALTZ IN TONIGHT
AND DROP, LIKE, EIGHT, SIX, AND
TWO --
>> THAT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> YOU HAVE TO READ THE GAME.
THE OVER AND UNDER IS ALMOST AT
240.
IT IS ALMOST AT 244 RECENT.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF POINTS.
UP AND DOWN.
>> TALK ME INTO IT.
>> ALL LOT OF JOKIC -- HE IS
AN OPEN GUY.
>> B THOMPSON SAYS HE MIGHT
HAVE EIGHT ASSISTS IN THE FIRST
HALF.
>> THAT IS THE CONFIDENCE I
NEED.
>> HE LITERALLY HAS NOT BEEN
UNDER EIGHT ASSISTS IN THE LAST
10 GAMES.
IT MIGHT BE LONGER, BUT THE
STATUTE I AM LOOKING AT ONLY
GOES BACK 10 GAMES.
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
I AM COOL WITH IT.
OKAY, ARE THEY OKAY WITH US
DROPPING DOWN TO PLUS 42?
>> WE HAVE TO GO.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> THUMBS UP OR THUMBS DOWN IF
YOU LIKE THE PARLAY, QUICKLY.
>> AGAIN -- TO GO THROUGH IT,
JORDAN POOLE, QUENTIN GRIMES,
PLUS  TWO MADE THREES, JORDAN
POOLE, 20 PLUS POINTS, JA
MORANT, 20 PLUS POINTS, AND
JOKIC, EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS.
>> IF YOU LIKE IT, THUMBS UP IN
THE CHAT.
IF NOT, THUMBS DOWN.
WHY IN?
YOUR FACE.
>> I AM NERVOUS.
>> I NEED GOOD VIBES.
I CAN FEEL IT.
I CAN FEEL YOUR VIBES.
>> I JUST WANT TO WIN.
I WANT TO WIN SO BAD.
>> IT HAS BEEN A WHILE.
>> LOOK AT THE THUMBS UP.
>> WE ARE GETTING SOME THUMBS
DOWN AND SOME THUMBS UP.
IT IS 50-50.
>> IT IS 50-50?
>> I DO NOT KNOW WHAT WE COULD
REPLACE.
WE HAVE TO FOOT HOUR -- PUT OUR
DOWN.
>> SWITCH JORDAN POOLE FROM 20
TO 25 PLUS.
IF HE WILL MAKE A LATE
ADDITION, I WOULD FEEL -- AS OR
NO?
>> HE SAID GIGA VALUE.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE WILL GO
QUICKLY.
>> I FEEL LIKE WE ARE UP
AGAINST -- WE WILL SWITCH IT
AND IT WILL BE FUNNY.
>> YEAH, THAT -- THAT WILL DO
IT.
>> LET'S DO IT.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DOING.
OKAY, YES, THIS IS FINAL.
JORDAN POOLE, LET'S GO UP.
NOW -- OKAY.
I'M NERVOUS.
JORDAN POOLE, THREE PLUS MADE
THREES QUENTIN GRIMES, TWO
PLAYERS MADE THREES JORDAN
POOLE, 20+ POINTS.
JOKIC, EIGHT PLUS ASSISTS AND
JA MORANT, 20 PLUS POINT.
THEY ADD UP TO +637 . I LIKE
THIS.
>> LET'S GO, GUYS.
LET'S GO.
>> I AM NERVOUS.
>> THEY ARE GIVING US THIS
NERVOUS ENERGY AND THAT IS OKAY.
>> IF YOU SWITCHED IT FROM 30
TO 25 FOR JA, WHAT DOES IT DO?
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> JUST TELL US.
>> NO, HE IS GETTING --
>> IF ANYTHING, TAKE A JORDAN
POOLE AND MAKE HIM THREE THREES.
>> NO, IT DROPS IT.
THAT IS A NO GO.
>> 637 -- WE ARE GOOD.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
>> GOODBYE.
WE ARE LOCKED IN, RYAN?
>> WE ARE.
>> GIVE IT TO THE ONE MORE
TIME.
>> THE POSITIVE.
HERE WE GO.
WE HAVE GOT JORDAN POOLE, THREE
PLUS ME THREES.
QUENTIN GRIMES, TWO PLUS THREE
THREES.
JORDAN POOLE, 25 PLUS POINTS.
JOKIC, EIGHT ASSISTS, AND  JA
MORANT 30 PLUS POINTS.
>> THERE IT IS.
THAT IS IT.
WE ARE DONE.
WE HAVE GOT TO GO WATCH SOME
GAMES.
WE HAVE TO GO WIN SOME MONEY.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY .  WE
ALSO HAVE TRAN60 BUT YOU MIGHT
CALL THE MICHAEL BALIN AND THEN
WE HAVE RYAN.
WE CALL HIM PRODUCER RYAN.
WE ARE OUT, PIECE.